[Musica]
buonasera vorrei parlarvi di questa
mosca e giuro che ci serve veramente un
gran coraggio per parlare di una mosca o
meglio di questa musica e nella mia
presentazione non parlerò solo di questa
mostra che agli occhi di tutti voi è un
organismo estremamente fastidioso noioso
che può creare dei problemi ma li
parlerò anche di cose interessanti ma
sicuramente non allegre parlerò di
cadaveri
parlerò di crimini e parlerò di come si
può mettere tutto insieme per cercare di
capire cosa è successo durante un
crimine
ma qual è la disciplina che unisce tutte
queste cose
il nome della disciplina che unisce
questa cosa è l'entomologia forense e
tutti voi conoscete uno tra i più
importanti entomologi forensi sono un
altro da un punto di vista prettamente
televisivo che hai grissom allora io con
lui condivido solo una cosa la
confusione sulla mia scrivania l'un
l'altro ma perché possiamo usare gli
insetti per capire cosa è successo
durante un crimine possiamo usarli
perché fondamentalmente loro sono tanti
e personaggi bizzarri come il
sottoscritto vanno in giro spendono loro
giornate con un retino o davanti al
microscopio possono trasferire
l'informazione che gli insetti ci
raccontano in contesti molto seri come
per l'appunto contesto in tribunale o in
un contesto quello storico per capire
cosa è successo nel passato come vi
dicevo gli insetti sono tanti ma quanti
sono gli stati sono animali
anche loro sono animali e rappresentano
ben il 75 per cento degli animali
attualmente conosciuti se uniamo agli
insetti i loro cugini gli scorpioni i
granchi piuttosto che i ragni arriviamo
al 87.5 per cento degli animali viventi
noi insieme ai pesci ed uccelli e
rettili
siamo più o meno il 4 per cento quando
si parla di biodiversità la biodiversità
sono loro ma se io transito qui in mezzo
chiedo 5 10 euro per proteggere il cervo
la balena l'aquila
più di qualcuno di voi metterà mano
portafoglio ma se le chiedessi 10
centesimi per salvare moschee moscerini
e zanzare non è detto che io riesco esca
vivo da questa stanza ma ricordatevi noi
siamo una specie loro sono almeno un
milione di specie su quindi sono
veramente tanti e dove li troviamo
ritroviamo più o meno ovunque li
troviamo sulle alte cime delle montagne
e li troviamo sulle spiagge del mare
addirittura ci sono gli insetti che
vivono sulle isole galleggianti di alghe
in mezzo all'oceano ritroviamo nelle
nostre nelle nostre campagne e gli
agricoltori sanno quanti danni gli
insetti possono fare altrettanto sanno
che se noi mangiamo gli ortaggi e frutti
e perché loro attraverso di loro c'è
l'impollinazione dei fiori li troviamo
nei borghi d'italia piccoli agglomerati
urbani ma li troviamo anche caotiche e
direi rumorose città loro ci sono ci
sono anche li ritroviamo anche in posti
più ameni un pochino più selvaggi come
possono essere i boschi troviamo alcuni
insetti che addirittura escono a vivere
nelle acque dei ruscelli nelle acque dei
torrenti posto che potremmo potrebbe
sembrare ai nostri occhi un pochino
estremo per lui setino di pochi
millimetri ma l'estremo per gli insetti
diciamo che è veramente più in là se
questo inverno andate sulle cime delle
nostre dolomiti potete incontrare questa
bellissima mosca che è meno fastidiosa
di quella che vi ho fatto vedere
all'inizio che è senza ali e che vive
zampettando tranquillamente sulle nevi
delle nostre montagne ma addirittura
abbiamo una mosca la cui larva vive nel
petrolio
nessuno di noi potrebbero resistere per
qualche minuto immerso in una vasca da
bagno di petrolio lei si sviluppa nel
petrolio quindi praticamente hanno
colonizzato tutti gli ambienti possibili
e immaginabili ma non solo gli ambienti
anche gli organismi li possiamo trovare
associate alle nostre blues che munuti
al pascolo
pensate quante volte la mucca muove la
coda per sbarazzarsi delle mosche e
anche associati ad altri animali che di
zampe ne hanno solo due e sono associati
con questi animali sia da veri pulci
pidocchi perché ci hai capelli non
nel mio caso e tutti voi sapete perché
non avete fatto esperienza durante una
bella e calda e secca estate trevigiana
la presenza delle zanzare che quindi
sono associate all uomo però l'uomo da
vivo come sono associate su l'uomo
all'uomo
quando questo è in vita le troviamo
associate anche al cadavere quando
questo ormai giace a terra privo di vita
e a questo punto gli insetti entrano
sulla scena del crimine ma più che
entrare sulla scena del crimine possiamo
dire che gli insetti si trovano già
sulla scena del crimine e sono
fondamentalmente dei testimoni
silenziosi piccoli che scappano anche
all'attenzione dei più e quindi ci
possono raccontare un sacco di
informazione su cosa è successo durante
l'evento criminale subito dopo ma che
tipo di insetti troviamo su una scena
del crimine degli insetti che sono direi
listati a lutto non hanno le colorazioni
bellissime delle farfalle piuttosto che
di certi coleotteri quindi alcune mosche
a mosca verde il moscone blu a mosca del
caso marzo per chi di voi stato in
sardegna ha mangiato il formaggio con le
larve ecco quella in alto è la moschina
responsabile di queste di quelle larve
considerata una delicatezza
io non l'ho mai provato ne penso che lo
proverò poi troviamo dei coleotteri
vedete anche queste somigliano un po i
maggiolini alle coccinelle ma anche
questi come colorazioni listate a lutto
e poi le tarme dei vestiti che se
invitaci bucano i maglioni quando saremo
morti
mangeranno i capelli continua a dire per
chi ce li ha
e i resti della pelle secca ma cosa ci
raccontano gli insetti gli insetti
fondamentalmente sono importantissime
per capire il tempo del decesso
voi mi direte ma a noi abbiamo visto un
sacco di serie sappiamo che il patologo
forense misura la temperatura guarda
rigor mortis guarda alle macchie
ipostatiche del corpo ed ha una sua
stima si questo è vero funziona
benissimo per le prime 72 ore dopo il
decesso
dopodiché il medico legale
il patologo non può più dire niente e a
questo punto arriva l'entomologo forense
utilizzati in 7 con una sorta di
orologio ma perché possiamo utilizzare
gli insetti come un orologio perché lo
sviluppo degli insetti e temperatura
dipendente se voi guardate dietro di me
vedete che lo sviluppo di un insetto
abbiamo l'adulto deporrà delle uova o
direttamente dell'arte
le larve diventano più grandi formano un
gozzo letto dentro abbiamo la
metamorfosi kafka da cui poi da questo
bozzetto uscirà un adulto e il ciclo
continua tutto questo dipende dalla
temperatura
quindi se io riesco a capire che insetto
a che stadio di sviluppo si trova che
temperatura c'era sulla scena disco a
fare una stima del tempo del decesso per
tempistiche più lunghe
devo vedere cosa succede durante la
decomposizione durante la decomposizione
né ci trasformiamo da freschi più o meno
assomigliamo come adesso
diventiamo un gruppetto di ossa quindi
ci trasformiamo da un punto di vista
fisica da un punto di vista chimico e
una serie di piatti da portata uno
dietro l'altro che sono appetibili per
diversi insetti a seconda dell insetto
possiamo fare una stima del tempo
solo questo no gli insetti ci raccontano
anche su un corpo è stato spostato voi
pensate una scena del crimine come un
bosco troviamo un cadavere su questo ci
sono degli insetti tipici della città
quindi possiamo tranquillamente
sostenere che il corpo è stato spostato
dalla scena primaria del crimine a una
secondaria ma immaginate che un cadavere
a terra con delle larve piccole un po
ovunque dell'arte grandi dimensioni
grandissima nella faccia torna il naso
la bocca è un indice di cocaina la
cocaina in qualche modo influenza
l'attività e il comportamento dell'uomo
ma al tempo stesso anche il
comportamento delle larve la crescita
delle larve e la cosa meravigliosa che
in assenza di tessuti che un tossicologo
può analizzare quindi manca il sangue
perché ormai è decomposto mancano i
tessuti molli
io posso utilizzare gli insetti che
trovo sulla scena del crimine per capire
la causa di morte se dovuta a una droga
quindi faccio le estrazioni dagli
insetti contro qualcosa che sembra
fantascienza ma il futuro che ormai
presente
in caso in cui il corpo viene rimosso
dalla scena del crimine di sicuro il
criminale non avrà rimosso tolto tutte
le levette che sono a terra io posso
identificare la vittima che era lì
presente
analizzando il dna dentro la pancia
delle mie mosche delle mie larghe ma non
solo andiamo oltre
se una zanzara fungesse chi ha commesso
il crimine e questo è già stato fatto
analizzando il sangue contenuto nella
pancia della zanzara io riesco a
identificare dare un nome e cognome e
non più sospetto ma al criminale che ha
commesso il crimine
poi nei casi vecchi all keys col keys
come li chiamano gli inglesi possiamo
riuscire a capire anche la stagione del
decesso
un caso successo 17 anni fa forse vi
ricorda qualcosa
guardando gli insetti presenti sul corpo
riusciamo a capire la stagione del
decesso
queste due mosche alle mie spalle una si
sviluppa fondamentalmente d'estate
quella verde l'altra invece o in
primavera un autunno
e siccome mi lasciano sulla scena del
crimine quel pozzo letto che vi ho fatto
di cui ho parlato prima
io posso trovarlo anche dopo molti anni
parliamo di secoli o di millenni
ed è qui che l'entomologia forense c'è
gioca un ruolo fondamentale per capire
le nostre radici e aiutarci a dare un
nome a chi un nome a uno dei tanti uno
dei 650 mila dispersi della prima guerra
mondiale che ogni tanto viene ritrovato
i cui resti sono ritrovati sulle nostre
montagne
pochi chilometri da qui vi voglio
raccontare per l'appunto la storia di
questo ragazzo che è stato trovato
qualche anno fa e sull'altipiano dei
sette comuni e quando è stato trovato
giaceva sotto pochi centimetri di terra
40 centimetri di terra
indossava un elmetto come questo e
quindi questo ci fa capire che era un
soldato italiano
abbiamo trovato le vertebre gli oneri i
femori e gli antropologi forensi hanno
capito che aveva 3 19 25 anni era
veramente un giovane ragazzo che era
andato all'assalto
la causa di morte una scheggia che gli
aveva perforato il cranio se curate la
ricostruzione questa scheda è passata
sotto appena sotto l'elemento quindi se
questo ragazzo fosse stato solo cinque
centimetri più basso
forse sarebbe stato il nonno di uno di
noi presenti in questa stanza oggi
bisogna dargli un nome abbiamo capito
che è un ragazzo giovane
sappiamo che era anche robusto di
corporatura
adesso dobbiamo restringere la lista
degli scomparsi gli dicevo prima e
abbiamo 650.000 della prima guerra
mondiale solo italiani e quindi bisogna
capire la stagione del successo quando è
morto perché perché va andrò a vedere
nella liste dei reggimenti che hanno
combattuto in quell'area chi è scomparso
in quella regione
e questo ce lo possono raccontare sugli
insetti nelle sue giberne infatti
abbiamo trovato i boccioletti di questi
insetti
cento anni fa e li abbiamo identificati
hanno tre nomi strani pro torni a terra
9 formia reggina fania canicola ris
però vi diranno niente i nomi è però a
noi che lavoriamo nel settore si dicono
moltissimo ci dicono che le per la prima
specie è presente solo in primavera e in
autunno raramente d'estate la seconda
invece è presente anche d'estate e la
terza che arriva dopo le prime è
presente esclusivamente durante l'estate
quindi facendo una serie di ragionamenti
che poi sono stati supportati da del
materiale che abbiamo trovato nei
vestiti di questo resti dei vestiti di
questo soldato abbiamo fatto l'ipotesi
che fosse scomparso fosse morto andando
all'assalto a fine primavera inizio
estate dato che poi è stato confermato
dagli studi storici ma il ragazzo
i resti erano sotto terra perché nessuno
si era accorto di lui perché non
l'avevano recuperato per il semplice
motivo che le prime due
i primi due insetti colonizzano i corpi
esposti il terzo invece che è arrivato
dopo i corpi sotto terra
l'ipotesi era stato coperto non dai suoi
commilitoni
ma del materiale spostato
dall'artiglieria da delle bombe cadute
nelle sue vicinanze
dato confermato storicamente e allora
quanta terra muove una bomba quando
esplode questo è un cratere di una bomba
della prima guerra mondiale sul piave
come vedete cerchiate in blu ci sono due
soldati li avete un'idea di quanta massa
di terra sia stata mossa e abbia
ricoperto il nostro soldato unendo i
dati di entomologia antropologia
genetica
stiamo cercando di ridare un nome a
questo ragazzo perché fa parte delle
nostre radici è il nostro presente e i
suoi valori saranno anche quelli mi
auguro del nostro futuro
e a questo punto volevo farvi una
domanda ma la faccio fare alla mosca con
la quale sono entrato dicendo che agli
occhi di molti una mosca è fastidiosa e
quindi la domanda che la mia mosca di fa
è questa
pensi ancora che sia solo fastidiosa
[Applauso]